actuellement il ya seulement 10 % à peu
près des parents qui ont accès
maternelle 80 il y en a au moins 30% qui
voudraient envoyer leurs enfants à la
maternelle quatre ans la maternelle 4
ans est ce une bonne chose pour l'avenir
des enfants est ce que d'aller à l'école
plus tôt dans la vie n'aura plus
productifs catherine ac est économiste
professeur d'économie à l'eau et j'ai eu
cam spécialisé en économie d'éducation
bonsoir bonsoir
est ce qu une maternelle quatre ans et
mieux qu'un cpe un centre de la petite
enfance pour le développement d'un
argent la réponse courte ces noms là le
milieu dans lequel l'enfant et que ce
soit à l'école ou de cpe c'est pas ça
qui va faire qu'on va se développer au
mieux ce qui va faire qu'il va être
développée mieux c'est que la qualité du
personnel sur place la qualité des
enseignants ou des éducatrices dans les
milieux de garde donc le fait que ce
soit l'école où que ce soit dans le cpe
c'est pas ça l'important l'importance et
la qualité du service que le système
québécois est capable de rendre dans les
deux réseaux donc on sait que par
exemple dans le milieu scolaire on étend
à pleine capacité
le réseau est contraint par le nombre
d'écoles qui le nombre de classes qui
l'a et le nombre d'enseignants qui l'a
donc à l'heure actuelle espérer ouvrir
beaucoup de matériel maternelle 4 ans et
offriront un service de grande qualité
c'est totalement réaliste mais on a des
endroits qu'on avait le ministre
d'éducation de la france qui dans
montréal ce matin donné une entrevue à
la radio
la france et trois en maternelle oui
elle est on a souvent dit que la france
avait tout un système d'éducation
bon il ya des critiques et des courriers
des comptes bien sûr mais la maternelle
3 en existe dans un pays avancé comme la
france oui là je veux pas démolir la
france au profil du québec mais le
québec est un système d'éducation qui
réussit très bien si on regarde les
résultats aux tests internationaux comme
pisa par exemple le québec performe de
manière excellente depuis plusieurs
années ce qui n'est pas le cas de la
france je dis pas qu'ils ont pas des
bonnes solutions à nous offrez
probablement mais je pense pas que le
fait d'aller à l'école à 3 ans soit
bénéfique les pays l'est
plus performant dans les tests
internationaux comme par exemple la
finlande commence par l'école à trois
ans là le village de le voir à l'école
c'est 6 en fin de saison
donc alors que chez nous c'est cinq ans
mais l'âge obligatoire en fait ces six
ans
ici aussi mais en pratique on commence à
5 ans bon alors là il ya un enjeu de
qualité d'organiser un réseau une
structure de réseau de qualité
supérieure c'est un enjeu de base
oui mais vous convenez en même temps
qu'il faut intervenir tôt dans l'enfance
pour être capable d'aider des enfants
surtout dans les milieux défavorisés
oui en fait beaucoup de mes travaux et
de mon travail se concentre sur but
justement promouvoir l'importance
d'investir taux est particulièrement
dans les milieux défavorisés
donc ce qui est arrivé avec le réseau
des cpe c'est que et de tout le réseau
des services de garde en fait c'est
qu'on n'a pas réussi à très bien
rejoindre les enfants des milieux
défavorisés
donc quand on regarde qui va en cpe on
voit rapidement que les enfants qui vont
en cpe deviennent beaucoup plus souvent
des quintile de revenu supérieure que
les enfants qui viennent des milieux
plus défavorisés donc on a un problème
de à rejoindre ses enfants l'on n'est
pas capable de les amener à participer à
ce réseau là donc un travail qui doit
être fait le sk interne est le 4e ne va
pas permettre cela
si c'était obligatoire même la
maternelle 4 ans est-ce qu'on
n'atteindrait pas un objectif de
rejoindre tous les enfants y compris les
enfants en milieu défavorisé de taille
oui peut-être si c'était obligatoire par
contre je doute beaucoup de la capacité
du réseau à offrir une qualité qui est
suffisant pour ses enfants le qu'on
parle d'investissement auprès des
enfants des milieux défavorisés
on parle d'investissements massifs
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on était prêt à
faire au québec donc souvent au québec
on va parler des études qui ont été
faits les études américaines a dit stop
et risque où tout se sait et les
étudiants étaient faits c'est programme
n'a été fait pour les enfants des
milieux défavorisés étaient des
programmes qui étaient beaucoup plus
soutenu que ce que nous on peut offrir
oui et bien par l'état puis aussi des
programmes il y avait une composante
d'intervention auprès des parents donc
il y avait des gens qui se rendaient
dans la maison des parents et
interagissez avec eux pour comprendre le
milieu de vie
enfants donc ce n'est pas juste d'amener
l'enfant dans un lieu puis de faire des
activités c'est beaucoup plus que ça
donc si on veut vraiment redresser la
barre je pense que c'est important cela
pour la redresser cette borloo va
falloir investir plus que ça de manière
ciblée qu'on n'est pas prêt à faire ce
on investit souvent de manière
universelle on n'est pas prêt à faire
des investissements ciblés en éducation
donc faudrait pouvoir le faire quand on
voit nos tout décrochage scolaire
particulièrement chez les garçons on a
fait des progrès important mais il reste
qu'il ya encore une grande fraction des
garçons de milieux défavorisés
particulièrement qui ont énormément de
difficultés ce rapport aux quand il
rentre à l'école il ya eu des études qui
sont sortis récemment qui parlait de
l'école les inégalités mais quand les
enfants arrivent à l'école les
inégalités sont déjà là c'est bien avant
ce qu'il faut commencer à redresser les
que l'école réduit quand même les
inégalités ça c'est une bonne question
on a pas d'évidence au québec d'études
que moi je connais qui a fait ça que
études et ça par contre on sait très
bien que un jeune qui vient d'un milieu
plus défavorisés qui axe à l'école qui
valent à l'université va réussir
beaucoup mieux à long terme donc
l'éducation en soit apporter un bénéfice
important est ce que l'école réduit les
inégalités observé ça c'est une autre
question mais clairement le système
québécois n'est pas plus et inégalitaire
que d'autres dans le raid canal et il
est clair qu'il faut augmenter la
diplomation le nombre de jeunes qui
arrivent à avoir un diplôme
parce que c'est payant sur le plan
économique sur le plan social c'est
extrêmement payant si on arrive à
relever les compétences pas juste donné
le bout de papier que ça vaut rien et je
prouve en économie vraiment relevé les
compétences à amener les jeunes à
réussir à l'école puis à s'engager à
l'école et à persévérer
on parle de bénéfices juste au niveau du
salaire individuel est là d'une personne
si on cumule les bénéfices si on arrive
à monter notre taux de graduation a par
exemple 85%
il reste encore 1 15% non comblés l'a
donc juste 85 on parle de bénéfices qui
pourraient se chiffrer à peu près de 275
milliards donc c'est beaucoup de
sociétés oui c'est une étude baa2 pierre
fortin qui a fait qui a fait 7 calcul
est donc donc ce n'est pas rien
et bien parce qu'on est capable mais
faut se donner les moyens donc est ce
que vous dites qu'il faut miser sur les
cpe
je dis qu'il faut miser sera un service
de qualité auprès des enfants
défavorisés de quelque forme qui peut
savoir mais il faut que ce soit un
service de qualité qui rejoint ses
enfants le doute que l'école est capable
de façon à quatre ans bon parfait en
tout cas on va de l'avant avec la
maternelle quatre ans le premier
ministre l'a encore répété aujourd'hui
les mines et d'éducation également
catherine ac vous êtes très intéressante
merci beaucoup merci bonne étoile et
pour cette explication